too expensive bad scripts and the Legacy
nobody wants to touch in sci-fi anything
is possible except a sequel to these
films
Tom Cruise is no stranger to sci-fi
having starred in films such as minority
reports and Edge of Tomorrow one that is
often overlooked however as 2013's
Oblivion directed by Joseph Kaczynski
Oblivion thoughtfully explores ideas of
isolation love and survival not only is
the movie visually stunning but it also
includes the supporting talents of Olga
kurolenko Nikolai Costa Waldo and Morgan
Freeman and features a breathtaking
soundtrack composed by the French
electronic band M83 Cruz plays Jack
Harper a technician who lives on a
remote base in a post-apocalyptic world
he and his partner Victoria played by
Andrea reisborough are seemingly the
only humans on Earth and that sat with
protecting the ruins of the planet from
Alien scavengers Harper believes that he
and Victoria will rejoin the remaining
human colonists on Saturn's moon once
they have completed their objective
however as they go forward with their
task Harper begins to question who and
what he is and if wasn't he and Victoria
are doing is right
I don't know what happened
but you're not who you think you are
Oblivion does leave us with lots of
questions that could be expanded upon
it's the kind of story that would really
lend itself to a prequel it would be
interesting to see a film explore how
the war ravaged Earth ended up this way
and what Harper's life was like
beforehand with Crews still in great
shape and the advancements of the Aging
technology have prequel with the same
cast wouldn't be out of the question
in the 2018 sci-fi film upgrade great
Trace played by Logan Marshall Green is
a mechanic living in a futuristic world
run by technology one day he and his
wife are attacked when their high-tech
car malfunctions the thugs murder Gray's
wife and he is left as a quadriplegic
following damage to his spine not helped
by the trauma of what happened the
previous C anti-tech gray suddenly
becomes completely reliant on it when he
signs up to be a test subject for an
experimental technology to help him walk
again it works but with some unintended
side effects I need your permission to
operate independently
thank you
upgrade shows what someone is capable of
doing when they're left with no choice
and the film's ending leaves plenty of
room for more exploration the experiment
leaves gray as an overpowered
supercomputer with no empathy for
Humanity and this offers so much
opportunity for a sequel or franchise
the good news is the filmmakers agree
and deadline announced in 2020 that
director Lee warnell and producer Jason
Blum were turning the movie into a
television series set a few years after
the events of the film a series will
focus on a new host as well as the way
that the government is using evolved
technology to deal with criminals and
the legal activity it might not be an
easy road to getting the series made
however in 2021 Blum told collider that
the first scripts didn't make the grade
saying we're working on the scripts
again so that we can get an order since
then news has gone quiet about the state
of the project but hopefully it'll get
off the ground soon
directed by Josh tranq Chronicle was a
surprise critical success and box office
hits when it was released in 2012. the
found footage film takes the idea of a
superhero's origin story and flips it on
his head to tell us a villain's origin
story instead delivering a film that his
heartfelt suspenseful and even
uncomfortable at times Andrew Detmer
played by Dane DeHaan is a high school
student who gets bullied by his peers
and father one day he along with his
cousin Matt played by Alex Russell and
popular jug Steve played by Michael B
Jordan stumbles across a meteor that
gives them telekinetic Powers at first
they use her abilities to enhance their
lives however as Andrew's suffering
grows so does his need to take power
consumed by rage he begins to see
himself as an apex predator and believes
everyone else is beneath him and should
be destroyed Chronicle ends with map
promising Andrew that he'll do good work
with his gifts but now that the world
has seen their powers what will Matt do
and how will Andrew's actions and death
haunt Matt into his adult life a
while screenwriter Max Landis had penned
a sequel trunk didn't want to move ahead
with her the director told polygon I
really didn't ever want to see Chronicle
2 happen that was my worst nightmare
unless he has a change of heart a
follow-up seems very unlikely
sci-fi series Firefly was something of
occult's hit when it was released with
Rotten Tomatoes even naming it as the
12th best sci-fi series of all time but
the western themed space are Pros
unceremoniously canceled after just one
season in 2002. fortunately the story
picks up with the 2005 film Serenity the
movie follows the same ragtag group of
outcasts and a Serenity spaceship whose
lives get upended when River Tam played
by Summer Glau a woman with psychic
powers and a strange past hides on board
unfortunately not enough people watched
it so the studio vetoed any more talk of
sequels while Die Hard Firefly fans have
been calling out for more Big Screen
Adventures for years they are yet to
materialize star Nathan Fillion told
Entertainment Weekly if I got 300
million dollars from the California
Lottery the first thing I would do is
buy the rights to Firefly make it on my
own and distributes it on the internet
so no more running
I am to misbehave in a later interview
with Esquire Fillion said that his
comments accidentally rallied the troops
as fans started raising money for him to
get the rights going forward he intends
to be more careful giving voice to his
pipe dreams
audiences are used to seeing some Crews
play The Dashing hero but 2014's Edge of
Tomorrow offers something new the
character he plays is a bit of a coward
Cruz plays PR officer major William cage
a man reluctantly thrust into a raging
war between humans and a seemingly
unbeatable race of aliens
says here you're deserter
says here you were caught impersonating
enough at one point in a battle cage
gets infected with alien blood just
before dying he miraculously wakes up 24
hours prior seemingly the only person
with memories of his time on the
battlefield it's Groundhog Day meets an
alien invasion story as cage dies
repeatedly in combat Force relive the
same battle he eventually becomes a
better fighter under the tuchelage of
Emily Blunt's Sergeant Rita ratuski who
had previously held the same ability
torque of the new chapter of Edge of
Tomorrow began almost immediately and in
2016 director Doug Lyman told collider
that he had plans to do a prequel in
2019 Entertainment Weekly confirmed that
an edge of tomorrow prequel was in
development at Warner Brothers but just
two years later it ironically seemed to
be stuck in a loop Emily Blunt told
Entertainment Weekly in 2021 that she
had read the treatment for Edge of
Tomorrow Too saying it was an amazing
script but I just don't know what the
future holds for it honestly I think the
movie's too expensive Robert the mecca
says 1997 feature contact based on Carl
Sagan's novel of the same name follows
Dr Ellie Airway played by Jody Foster a
communication specialist who finds proof
of alien life tasked with going to space
in order to make first contact with them
her journey challenges her in ways she
never anticipated contact is a layered
philosophical story that just happens to
be sci-fi as well it's not a big
Blockbuster action flick like
Independence Day instead it offers a
slow build that leaves you questioning
the nature of life and what it means to
make true connections
they should have said
[Music]
Jodie Foster is not an actor who likes
to do sequels she famously passed on
reprising her role as Clarisse in the
sequel to Silence of the Lambs unless
the plot is exactly what she wants since
contact is a movie she holds very close
to her heart a sequel is unlikely Carl
Sagan died while the film was in
production speaking to vulture about him
Foster said that to be responsible in a
way for the legacy of Carl Sagan is
really amazing to me that feels just
like a really big deal in my life until
I sat down with Carl I don't think I
really
thought much about the vastness of the
universe a sequel to contact isn't
totally out of the question
co-screenwriter Michael Goldenberg told
vulture that he has a pitch for a
limited series but so far nothing has
come from that
Christopher Nolan likes to take
audiences on unexpected Journeys and his
2010 sci-fi film Inception does just
that the film plays around with the
dreams and how they can be powerful
motivators although much of inception
feels like a heist film the story is
ultimately about the lens the father
will go to in order to be with his
family Leonardo DiCaprio plays Dom Cobb
a man wrongly accused of murdering his
wife do the children Miss
I can't imagine
to avoid arrest he fled the country and
hasn't seen his children since Cobb
Works as an extractor using experimental
dream technology to infiltrate a
person's subconscious to extract
information for his clients when
businessman Mr Saito asked him to commit
to an impossible job and promises he can
finally return home to his children if
he pulls it off com agrees the ending of
inception is deliberately ambiguous
audiences never find out if covers in
the real world with his kids or still in
the dream world while it is an audacious
way to end a film would love to learn
more what about the rest of the
characters is Cobb trapped in a dream
how will it affect them what happens if
he wakes up
based on the bug by Andy Weir released
God's 2015 film The Martian Stars Matt
Damon as botanist Dr Mark Watney after
finding himself stranded on Mars Whitney
is Tesla trying to survive or NASA works
on a rescue mission to bring him back
home set in the year 2035 the sci-fi
film offers a fresh take on the genre
with a focus on pure survival rather
than the discovery of alien creatures in
the face of overwhelming odds I'm left
with only one option
I'm gonna have to science the out
of this the biggest challenge is Watney
faces a finding unrationing basic
necessities like food and water and
trying to maintain his sanity the
Martian was loved by audiences and
critics alike and it was nominated for a
total of seven Oscars but it's unlikely
that a sequel will materialize however
the rise to Andy Weir's follow-up novel
Artemis described as an adrenaline
charge crime keeper have been acquired
by 20th Century Fox and the new Regency
Akira imagines a post-apocalyptic World
in which Tokyo has become neo-tokyo a
dark place filled with violence and
Corruption chotaro Canada is the leader
of a motorcycle gang who discovers a
group of people with telekinetic Powers
living in neo-tokyo as well as others
who want to use that power for their own
means Akira introduces a bleak and
violent world but one that is also
thought-provoking and challenging since
this release it's been the subject of
hyperbolic praise with days declaring it
the most important animation of all time
while there have been numerous attempts
to turn Akira into a live-action movie
with Warner Brothers first acquiring the
rights in 2002 so far nothing has
emerged The Story presents a number of
challenges but that's not to say people
aren't trying to bring it back taika
waititi was the most recent director
tipped to do the live-action remake but
his plans got pushed so he could do the
Thor movies in 2021 waititi told Wyatt
he still wants to do the film saying I'm
still trying I don't want to give up on
that
Steven Spielberg's Ready Player One
adapted from the Ernest Klein novel
brings together Nostalgia pop culture
and a hugely enjoyable adventure story
in a dystopian future people find solace
in the virtual reality game called Oasis
in the game you can be whoever and
whatever you want Wade watts is a lonely
teenager who goes by the name of
parsaval in Oasis when the founder of
the game dies it's announced that
whoever can solve a puzzle and find the
golden key will become the new owner of
the game if you're watching this I'm
dead Wade is that sermon to win and
embarks on a treasure hunt that takes
him to places he never dreamed of by the
film's end Wade makes a decision
regarding Oasis that changes the course
of every single person's life on the
planet it's such a huge moment and would
love to see what the repercussions of
his decision have on Humanity
fortunately a sequel to the novel Ready
Player 2 was released in 2020. although
it was universally panned by critics
Klein told inverter the feature film
adaptation of Ready Player 2 is in the
early stages of development but time
will tell whether or make it to the big
screen given the novels poor reception
as a debut feature from writer and
director Andrew nickel Gattaca is a
pretty impressive first offering the
movie stars Ethan Hawke Uma Thurman and
Jude Law And as a thoughtful exploration
of the meaning of life in an advanced
society that uses genetics to determine
a person's place in the world in the not
so distant future parents are able to
splice together the best part of their
genes to make a genetically Superior
child anyone that's born the
old-fashioned way is considered to be
inferior and given a lower standing in
society because of it Hawk portrays
Vincent Freeman one of those unlucky
children he meets a genetically Superior
Jerome Eugene Morrow played by Jude Law
a former Olympic athlete who's become
paralyzed the two decide to cheat the
system and Vincent pretends to be Jerome
they won't believe
that one of their Elite could have
suckered them all this time with his now
Superior standing Vincent gets a job
working at gattagar as a navigator for a
space project to Saturn's moon the film
ends with Vincent being allowed to keep
Jerome's life and he leaves for his
mission what happens to him in the world
that's been introduced is anyone's guess
but a sequel or even a prequel could
explore the moral implications of
genetic advances and what it means for
the people who get left behind because
of it unfortunately Nicole seems to have
closed the door on a sequel project in
an interview with fandom he said I don't
know that there needs to be a sequel
once you've said it do you need to say
it again we'll leave it to your
imagination better that you write the
sequel in your mind than I write it
starring's a gurney Weaver Alan Rickman
and Tim Allen Galaxy Quest is a Sci-Fi
cult classic that everyone needs to
experience while on the surface it looks
to be a film that just pokes fun at Star
Trek it really is so much more than that
it's a fun story about how Fame and
Fortune can ruin relationships and
sometimes you just need a quick trip
around the universe to make things right
again the film follows a group of actors
from the canceled Sci-Fi show Galaxy
Quest for the most part the cast can't
stand the show's original lead Jason
Nesmith played by Tim Allen however when
a group of aliens abdugs the cast
believing what they've watched to be
rather than Fiction the actors
face the biggest challenge of their
careers being actual Heroes this is
great you know usually it's just
cardboard walls in a garage Star Trek is
a franchise that seems to run and run so
it is only right that Galaxy Quest
should receive the same treatment
especially as a film ends with a cast
getting their show renewed collider
reports that Amazon Prime is poised to
revive Galaxy quests as a television
series however following the tragic
passing of Alan Rickman they paused
their plans Weaver shares it if the
Revival series does move forward it will
focus on a younger Galaxy Quest cast
joining forces with the remaining
original cast members for another
adventure in space when you talk about
cult classic Sci-fi films no list is
complete without 1997's The Fifth
Element the film stars Mila Jovovich as
Lilo the embodiment of the titular Fifth
Element who must combine herself with
the other elements to stop the great
evil from destroying everything luckily
she falls into the cab of New Yorker
Corbin Dallas and he helps her on her
journey to save the world in many ways a
Fifth Element could be considered as
hugely ahead of its time a sentiment
with which director Luke bassan agrees
Hassan points out that Not only was the
movie more comedy than action but it
also had a woman as a primary action
star this combines with the outlandish
costumes designed by Jean-Paul Gaultier
and the decision to have one of the main
characters unable to speak English made
the film A Hard Sell audiences didn't
quite know what to make of it and this
was reflected in its disappear initial
bugs office figures which put a stop to
any talk of a sequel however given
audiences receptiveness to the weird and
wonderful and the subsequent cult stasis
of The Fifth Element a sequel would
likely be welcome just because Lilo and
Dallas Save the Planet once doesn't mean
that they can't do it again what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger
directed by Christopher Nolan 2014's
Interstellar explores the possibilities
of wormholes time displacement and above
all else family it's an emotional tale
of a father who leaves his children in
the hopes of giving them a better life
with food running out on the planet
growing closer to mass level Extinction
Earth can no longer sustain humanity and
so an alternative place to live must be
found
us a new home
by the time you return
I will have solved the problem of
gravity Matthew McConaughey plays single
dad Cooper who is tasked with leading a
team to find a new habitable planet
while Interstellar tells a beautifully
poignant story it's ultimately has a sad
ending for Cooper when he eventually
gets back home after many years have
passed his young daughter is on her
deathbed
[Music]
Cooper leaving once more to find his
mission partner Dr Amelia brand who is
still traveling alone in space somewhere
with no idea about what happened to
Earth and Humanity a story about their
Adventures of being intriguing tale
especially after the success that
Interstellar enjoyed upon its release
while doing the Press tour for
Interstellar in 2014 McConaughey told
Sky news that a sequel was possible but
nothing has come of it yeah
E.T the Extraterrestrial is one of Pop
culture's defining sci-fi films from the
director who has made a number of such
films in his career Steven Spielberg
with the Perfect Blend of nostalgia
Whimsy and effective storytelling ET is
the blueprint of how to make a
successful family-friendly sci-fi movie
the film tells an emotional tale about a
young boy Elliot and his new alien
friend E.T who finds himself stranded on
Earth the two former beautiful bonds
that transcend species they connect over
their shared experience of feeling
separated from their families most of
the adult characters in the film react
to E.T with fear and suspicion but
Elliot recognizes the gentleness and
good in him the film ends with E.T going
home which is his mission from the
beginning but there is heartbreak on
both sides when he has to say goodbye to
Elliot while the idea of seeing these
beloved characters and another feature
would be welcome it feels like if a
sequel were going to come to light it
would have happened already following
the success of ET the studio did push
the idea of a follow-up but nothing came
of it speaking to slash film the
possibility of a sequel actor Henry
Thomas said I think it should be left
alone a reunion of sorts took place in
2019 featuring some of the original
casts including Thomas reuniting with
the lovable alien for a holiday
commercial the former Child Star went on
to say I think the commercial was as
close as we're going to get to a sequel
and that's why Spielberg okayed it but
Galaxy Quest does for Star Trek space
fools does for Star Wars offering an
exceptionally goofy Take On The Familiar
tropes of the iconic franchise while
occasionally brutal in the way it pokes
fun at some of the more ridiculous plot
points in Star Wars Spaceballs is a film
that doesn't take itself too seriously
it's loving Carefree approach to its
Prestige is irresistibly charming film
follows the kidnapping of Princess
Vesper who is being held hostage by Dark
Helmet Darth Vader asked buddy holds her
for ransom in the hope of obtaining air
his planet has depleted his Air Supply
fortunately she is rescued by Bad Boys
space Pilots Lone Star and his half-man
half dog partner bath many fans of the
film assume that another story was in
the works especially after Spaceballs
teased various titles for sequel films
however nothing has come out yet it's a
q a event in 2017 Mel Brooks talked
about the possibility of doing another
film especially since the first movie
became a cult classic unfortunately as
many of the original cast members have
now passed away any news stories will
need to feature and new cast and be told
in a way that would honor those who came
before
while technically dread is a reboot of
the 1995 film Judge Dredd starring
Sylvester Stallone 2012 film Bears very
little resemblance to the previous movie
and they appear to be connected in name
and Title Character only as the only
film on this particular Universe 2012's
dread earns a place on this list in a
dystopian city called Mega City one
judges had the power to act as judge
jury and executioner dread played by
Carl Urban takes rookie Cassandra
Anderson played by Olivia thorby with
him to a 200 story apartment to
investigate a murder the building is
controlled by a violent drug lord named
Mama made by Lena Headey he's a
formidable foe but she meets her match
in Judge Dredd
but as for you Mama
judgment time
critics praised red the fans have turned
it into a cult classic but the movie
failed to recoup its 50 million dollar
budget with Amiga worldwide Hall of 41
million dollars while the 2018 comic
dread final judgment is an official
sequel to the film we have yet to see
anything new on screen Olivia thrillby
Express her enthusiasm for a dread
sequel telling collider in 2021 I was
always the number one advocate of
getting a sequel for dread if there is
still talk of there being a sequel 10
years later I'm all foreign
2002 is Minority Report has an
incredible amount of talent both in
front of and behind the camera with Tom
Cruise in the leading role and Steven
Spielberg in the director's chair Cruz
plays Chief John anderton the commanding
officer of the pre-crime unit an
experimental prototype program designed
to stop murders before they happen
initially John wholeheartedly believes
in pre-crime until he Witnesses a murder
that he's about to commit in the future
once John Styles investigating Ian
covers damaging evidence regarding their
supposedly foolproof unit the premise
for minority reports is instantly
engaging and it feels like a story that
could expand into a franchise or
multiple installments I'm
[Music]
the pre-crime unit uses a special
ability of three humans called precogs
who have the ability to see the future
and witness crimes before they happen
with their skills proven to be fallible
it opens up a number of questions about
them that a sequel could address one of
the rare exceptions on this list
Minority Report was brought back as a
television show airing in 2015 the story
takes place a little over 10 years after
the film and follows one of the precogs
who still retains her ability
unfortunately the series was canceled by
Fox after just one season but there's
still room for the story to continue on
the big screen
foreign